buenos días raúl muchas gracias bueno
tenemos que comprender como como
llegamos a esta situación no entre 1861
y 1915 el imperio otomano le había
amputado el líbano a las principales
ciudades del litoral dejándolo sin
puerto y simple alicia cultivable y fue
así entonces como los libaneses quedaron
recluidos en la montaña libanesa con dos
tercios de territorio menos que sus
límites naturales territorio que fue
conocido como el pequeño líbano sin
embargo desde ese periodo hay que
rescatar lo importante que fue la
creación de un reglamento orgánico
mediado por potencias europeas y
otomanas que consistía en una semi
autonomía del pequeño en el líbano
gobernada por un cristiano no libanés
pero asistida por un consejo
administrativo de doce miembros
compuesto por maronitas rusos turistas
chiítas ortodoxos y mezquitas que en
cierta forma ha servido de prototipo
para la forma de gobierno que existe hoy
eso es muy importante para poder
comprender la situación hoy en 1915
sucedió que los otomanos abolieron el
reglamento orgánico sometiendo a los
libaneses a cuatro años de terror
con tamaña mediante un bloqueo y durante
ese tiempo que coincidió con el
genocidio armenio y el genocidio de los
cristianos siríacos y ortodoxos un
tercio de la población murió de hambre y
otro tercio micro américa eso no es
tenido en cuenta en la historia no es
muy conocido digamos porque ha sido
eclipsado en general por el genocidio
armenio pero todos los pueblos
cristianos y los pueblos del medio
oriente en esa época ha sufrido mucho
luego del colapso del imperio otomano al
finalizar la primera guerra mundial el
consejo administrativo del pequeño
líbano decidió enviar una delegación a
la conferencia de paz de parís de 1919
encabezada por el patriarca maronita
espías hájek cze para reclamar el
reconocimiento de la independencia del
líbano proclamada por el gobierno y el
pueblo libanés el 20 de mayo de 1919 y
la restauración del líbano en sus
fronteras históricas y naturales bueno
esta esta visión de la delegación
libanesa finalmente fue coronada con
éxito y poco tiempo después de la
conferencia
al remo el primero de septiembre de 1920
en beirut si el general músculo es junto
al patriarca hayek y al mosto bustafán
asia el proclamó en presencia de los
jefes religiosos el estado de el gran
líbano así y de esta manera se
restablecieron las fronteras geográficas
e históricas y se creó entonces un
mandato francés temporario que duró
hasta que se promulgó la constitución en
libanesa en 1926 alcanzando
definitivamente la independencia de 1943
por eso bueno es importante entender qué
es lo que lo que sucede hoy en el líbano
y la importancia de la creación del
estado de liberal líbano hace
exactamente 100 años hoy